caméra
euh une fois qu'elle est complètement installée, allez-
y et verrouillez-la
, puis parcourez les étapes suivantes
pour aller de l'avant et faites
ça d'accord
quelques vues fantastiques de la vue haute
définition de
kate rubin
maintenant dans cette journée orbitale au-dessus du canada
s'approchant d'un merci du sud-est
vous et ike si vous pouvez euh
passer à bravo trois
et enfoncer à nouveau ces boulons s'il
vous plaît je vais copier et ils vous remettront cette
diapositive en premier d'accord
je suis prêt à prendre le contrôle et vous l'obtenez
d'accord j'ai le contrôle
double face et  alors ike
traduira vers le côté deux bravo et pliera
l'
épandeur de sacs verrouillé le brocoli
je suis au poste de travail comme si vous pouviez voir
mes pieds
ou deux l'une des unités murales là-bas et
commencer à
enlever la combinaison qui comprend
enlever le casque et  gants